[Musique]
le café politique tous les 15 jours ici
y Montini le Bretonneux nous nous
installons au bistro du théâtre bonjour
et bienvenue pour ce numéro bestof sire
de l'agglomération de 5qutin en Evelin
se sont prêtés depuis le mois de
septembre à cet exercice ils sont de
droite de gauche du centre et ils ont
pour point commun d'avoir vécu la
première alternance en plus de 30 ans de
la structure voici quelques morceaux
choisis de leur
[Musique]
confidence tout d'abord 50 ans en
iveline après les élections en mars
dernier vous êtes devenu le premier
adjoint de la communauté d'agglomération
en charge des questions économiques La
droite majoritaire sur le territoire
c'est inédit il y a donc un match qui
s'est engagé avec Montini le Bretonneux
entre vous et Michel logier pour
récupérer la présidence pourquoi vous
vous n'êtes pas devenu président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 51 écoutez
d'abord depuis 42 ans dans dans cette
intercommunalité il y avait pas eu de
démocratie parce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'il y a pas d'alternance en
42 ans pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a pas eu
aucune alternance en 42 ans pour c'est
le choix des électeurs aussi oui
attendez les électeurs est-ce qu'ils
sont qu'ils sont vraiment bien
considérés de façon neutre dans dans
dans cette histoire c'est vrai que c'est
préoccupant quand on arrive on se dit
comment une structure comme ça pu se
maintenir pendant 42 ans sans al bon
c'est une vraie question qui mérite un
coloc deuxièmement non écoutez moi je
m'entends très bien avec Michel
logier a priori il y a deux communes qui
ont fait gagner donc Saint-Quentin c'est
montigé lancour on attendait par manie
mais bon ça pas été comme ça que ça
s'est fait bon après on s'est réparti
les choses bon moi il est évident que
bon il y a de fortes Chan qu'on me
renvoie au législativ bon s'il y a des
législatives je sais pas bon donc je
vais pas comme ça cumuler tous les tous
les tous les postes je pense que Michel
logier est plus je dirais que c'est
c'est plus simple pour lui et je crois
qu'on on en a parlé fallit quelqu'un
plus consensuel aussi quelqu'un plus
centriste qui permett aussi de rassurer
la gauche parce qu'il faut réussir à
gouverner même si vous avez la majorité
ça reste assez serré à la communauté
d'agglomération donc il faut quelqu'un
qui arrive à brasser un petit peu les
différentes tendances c'était plus
facile avec Michel log est-ce que vous
avez eu cette réflexion non non je non
je crois pas non vous savez de toute
façon vous avez la majoritéon vous
majorit vous une majorité même à une
voix c'est pas ce qui pas le cas mais
vous bon il y a une majorité quand même
qui est claire donc avec Michel on s'est
réparti les choses très très simplement
et c'est Mo dire moi-même qui a fait
appel à ce qu'on veut pour lui comme
président en tout cas vous arrivez aux
affaires et pour la première fois on
retrouve un homme politique de droite du
centre droit à 5quenttins en iveline
est-ce qu'à ce moment-là vous vous dites
ça y est enfin on va récupérer ce qu'on
a pas eu par le passé est-ce qu'il y a
un petit sentiment aussi de de revanche
à ce moment-là vis-à-vis de la gauche
qui a toujours détenu l'agglomération de
5at oui tout à fait mais je pense que
pour nous ça a toujours été un challenge
on en a rêvé hein pendant pendant très
longtemps de toute façon quand est en
politique c'est pour essayer de faire
triompher ses idées sa façon de voir les
choses sauf que c'est pas vous qui avez
toute la maîtrise ce sont les électeurs
qui on décident et au mois de mars
dernier le résultat nous a donné la
possibilité de pouvoir gérer cette ville
vous savez on a bien examiné on a bien
regardé depuis longtemps en plus cette
ville on la connaît cette
cetteomration pour revenir sur cette
question il y a pas de revanche de
sentiment de de se dire voilà il y a des
choses qu'on a pas eu là on va les avoir
et et peut-être même que cette fois-ci
les dossiers pour les autres communes à
gauch va pas les accorder je pense pas
que moi je ah non absolument pas ou
alors ou alors je veux dire moi c'est
que vous vous me connaissez mal je crois
pas voir cette image là je suis pas en
situation de revanche par contre je suis
en situation de prouver qu'en gérant
autrement on peut aller encore plus loin
c'est tout c'est c'est la seule
différence il y a pas de revanche à voir
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé puisque
je suis quand même j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour la démocratie donc jusqu'à
présent la population nous avait pas
donné la possibilité d'être aux commande
aujourd'hui i nous l'avons et bien je
sans esprit de revanche mais par contre
avec beaucoup d'ambition prouver que ce
que nous souhaitons faire était mieux
que et mieux sera mieux que ce qui se
faisait avant est-ce que vous avez fait
des erreurs pendant la campagne alors je
pense que vous voulez sans doute évoquer
le fait que c'était une campagne sur les
municipales alors qu'il y avait un autre
enjeu et qu' y avait l'enjeu de
l'agglomération et si je vous pose aussi
cette question vous l'avez peut-être
entendu c'est Robert Cadalbert qui était
dans votre majorité sur le précédent
mandat qui aujourd'hui est retiré de de
de la politique qui s'est exprimé qui
est revenu sur la campagne et il disait
que lui aurait préféré que la campagne
se fasse sur l'agglomération il a aussi
exprimé son son regret d'avoir été un
petit peu pousser vers la sortie
d'ailleurs vous pourrez peut-être réagir
à ça même siil dit les choses
aujourd'hui sont comme ça mais
effectivement on m'a fait comprendre
qu'il fallait mieux que je m'en aille
d'abord sur la question des des erreurs
pendant la campagne c'est très difficile
de répondre à cette question parce que
dire qu'il y a erreur un maire qui dans
sa commune a fait 68 % dire qu'il y a
erreur quand Bertrand Ouillon a fait un
score inattendu je vous rappelle que
tout le monde se demandait si ça allait
passer mais ceci dit oui mais après on
peut aussi parler des communes où la
droite était déjà implanté a très
fortement progressé on peut citer lour
montinil Bretonneux avec plusieurs
candidats il y av pas seulement deux
candidats et une élection malgré tout au
prier j'allis venir finalement c'est là
où la gauche est minoritaire qui a eu
insuffisance et j'ajouterais qu'on a une
situation tout à fait particulière à
voisin le Bretonneux je rappelle qu'à
voisin le Bretonneux il y a eu un duel
entre guillemets en politique hein c'est
pas entre le le maire sortant et Candat
droiteit deux candidat de droite
qu'est-ce qui se passe euh bah forcément
euh les gens veulent voter euh euh
efficace il se ditent lequel je vais
choisir résultat euh on n pas eu de
délégué par exemple la voisin de Breton
donc c'est pour la c'est la raison pour
laquelle je disais tout à l'heure que au
fond euh au niveau des élections
municipales les candidats de gauche il
suffit de regarder ce qui s'est passé
partout ailleurs en France les candidats
de gauche se sont très très très bien
comportés mieux que ça même et que par
contre de par le mécanisme de la loi et
des délégués on a eu ce résultat j' dire
rraque he
c'està-dire pense l'erreur l'erreur
c'est ça aurait été je sais pas si on
peut parler d'erreur mais en tout cas il
aurait fallu trouver le moyen que par
exemple la voisin le bretonux il ait pas
une focalisation sur simplement les deux
candidats de droite ce qui est ce qui a
laissé inaudible complètement la gauche
et puis vous l'avez dit aussi là où on
est minoritaire ça a était dans le
contexte national beaucoup plus
difficile
vous êtes professeur d'anglais à
l'origine comment vous avez découvert la
politique alors un peu par hasard même
si je crois pas vraiment au hasard en
fait mais quand je suis arrivée à à
voisin ça devit être en
1998 en fait j'ai quand j'ai aménagé il
y avait une créperie à côté de chez moi
qui s'est transformé en pub
et il y a eu énormément de bruit de
tapage nocturnes enfin c'était assez
compliqué et donc du coup j'ai bah j'ai
pris un peu les choses en main j'ai fait
une pétition dans le quartier non pas
pour fermer le peup mais pour demander à
ce qu'il y ait des horaires et à ce que
je dirais la tranquillité du du
voisinage soit respectée et c'est à ce
moment-là que sont arrivés les
élections les élections municipales
arrivaient de de 2001 et la parité était
devenue obligatoire donc ils avaient
besoin de femmes et sérieusement parce
que voilà d'être une femme en politique
ça peut aider aussi et donc ils ont
repéré quelqu'un qui ma fois avait su
peut-être sffirmé dans le quartier et
donc ils sont venus enfin l'équipe de
Monsieur B de l'époque est venu me
chercher pour être sur liste voilà
comment comment les choses ont démaré
entique on va s'arrêter sur ce moment où
vous quittez tout de même la majorité
parce que les propos sont durs des deux
côté aussi bien d'Alexis BIAT donc le
maire en place que de que de votre part
vous écrivez quand on est première
adjointe à voisin on sait ou bien on
démissionne c'était sur un détract qui a
été distribué c'est un moment difficile
pas sur le plan politique mais sur le
plan humain déjà ah oui oui oui ça a été
un moment très difficile sur le plan
humain parce que ce sentiment de pas
avoir été écouté de pas avoir d'avoir
été mise de côté de de plus en plus plus
les élections approchaient et plus on me
mettait sur la touche alors que je pense
que j'ai apporté ma pierre que j'ai
beaucoup soutenu monsieur Biet en toutes
les épreuves qu'il a traversé he je ve
dire en 2001 j'étais à ses côté quand il
y a eu le le fameux PCH c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça que je me suis retrouvé
adjointe en 2008 j'étais à ses côté
quand il y a encore eu une une session
dans l'équipe et j'ai trouvé que le
retour était quand même très très léger
on va dire et humainement en fait le
deuxè mandat humainement était très
compliqué début en politique 1990 14 ans
président du conseil municipal et oui
président du conseil municipal des
jeunes de Mani lesamo c'était quoi les
motivations à l'époque les motivations
c'était bah j'étais délégué de classe au
collège et et puis avec des amis on a
découvert ce nouveau conseil municipal
des jeunes et on s'est dit B allez on
s'intéresse à notre commune j'étais déjà
adhérant dans des associations en tant
que jeune et benah on a voulu apporter
un petit peu notre notre pierre à
l'édifice tout simplement cé aussi
simple que ça mais vous avez pris goû à
la politique he 95 ensuite conseiller
municipal 2001 maire adjoint vous êtes
carriériste en politique c'est ça
l'ambition c'est de gravir tous les
échelons et non pas du tout sinon
j'aurais certainement pris d'autres
voies des écoles ou ou bien grimper à
l'intérieur de certains partis politique
d'autres le font c'est pas du tout ce
que j'ai fait justement l'engagement en
politique ça remonte à quand pour vous
vous êtes diplômé de l'ESJ l'École
Supérieure de Journalisme vous avez été
ensuite au nouvelle de Versailles au
début des années 80 responsable de
l'information régionale aussi sur le
radio CVS canal versaill stéréo c'était
une des premières radio librees des
années 80 alors à quel moment vous avez
eu cette fibre et politique vous vous
êtes dit le journalisme ça me suffit pas
de relater ce que font les politiques
moi aussi je vais être acteur oh ça ça a
été beaucoup plus long que ça ça été
beaucoup plus long que ça puisque dans
un premier temps je suis venu travailler
au côté de Nicolas Abou j'ai créé son
cabinet tout le service de communication
donc ben travaillant au quotidien avec
des élus petit à petit bien ça vous
laisse la possibilité de réfléchir de
bien analyser ce qui peut se faire et
c'est comme ça que vous vous arrivez
petit à petit dans le monde politique
vous savez aujourd'hui moi je suis maire
de Montini président de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin je peux
vous dire j'avais jamais pensé même à
brasant h mais les choses sont venues
tout naturellement donc moi je prends la
vie comme elle est et comme elle vient
surtout et j'essaie d'être toujours à la
hauteur des des challenges qui me sont
présentés non non j'ai eu un parcours
finalement auquel je m'attendais
absolument pas puisque je voulais être
journaliste de presse écrite dans le
sport je me suis retrouvé alors je l'ai
fait pendant quelques temps je me suis
retrouvé à la radio ensuite j'ai
travaillé dans la communication d'une
collectivité je suis parti dans le privé
aussi m'occuper de l'affichage extérieur
dans un grand groupe voilà donc c des
choses auxquelles j'avais jamais pensé
et puis ben effectivement
l'environnement de la politique c'est
peut-être là où que je me suis le plus
épanoui et c'est comme ça donc que je
suis revenu travailler à Montini et s
vous êtes attaché à ce parcours de de
journaliste il en reste quoi d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui du journaliste reste quelque
chose il en reste je suis à l'aise quand
je suis face à vous déjà parce que
j'étais à votre
place il y a quelques années voilà ça
c'est pas la première chose et la
deuxième chose oui effectivement parce
que j'ai toujours plein d'amis qui sont
restés dans le dans le métier et que
j'entends à la radio que je vois la télé
Nicola PointCarré Pascal Clark Philippe
zigraf voilà ce sont des amis avec qui
on a commencé aujourd'hui ça me fait
toujours plaisir quand je les retrouve
de me sentir un petit peu avec eux votre
parcours politique pour le comprendre
justement vous êtes né en scène saint à
Montreuil famille modeste vous avez
travaillé dès l'âge de de 16 ans d'où
vous vient cette colère j'emploie ce
mot-là contre le socialisme le
communisme ce sont deux tendances
politiques que vous n'appréciez
particulièrement pas vous n'avez aucune
sympathie pour ni les socialistes ni les
communistes d'où ça vient ce cette cette
colère écoutez j'étais à montrey dansm
comme vous le dites et et donc à montre
cétait très communiste bon donc tous mes
copains étaient communistes alors ils
m'emmenaient au au faites machin alors
et j'étais dans j'étais socialiste entre
guillemets pendant 3 moisamais pris ma
carte mais j'étais avec j'allais aux
réunion d'ailleurs il y a Julien Dr un
jour qui a cité ça l'Assemblée nationale
ça fait rire à tout le monde quand il a
dit que j'étais un ancien socialiste bon
bref mais c'est vrai mais en même temps
je me souv j'avais un copain là-bas il
était ouvrier d'ailleurs c'est un garçon
qui qui travaille dans une petite PME
alors et il disait toujours du bien de
son patron alors dans je me souviens
dans la structure socialiste on dis mais
comment tu peux dire du bien de ton
patron enfin il t'exploite c'est un type
qui n rien à de toi et et je
trouvais ça très excessif quoi et et au
bout d'un moment le type il avait
tellement remonté mais quiess engueuler
avec son patron et son patron l'a foutu
dehors et là il est revenu cette espèce
de cellule et il dit ben voyez je me on
m'a foutu dehors et alors les
socialistes ont dit bah tu vois on avait
raison c'éit un salot j'ai trouvé ce
j'ai trouvé ça insoutenable cette
technique de
manipulation ils vendent de la haine
quoi ils lui ont vendu de la haine du
patron de l'économie de marché du
capitalisme et en fait ils l'ont mis en
échec et lui il faisait payer le train
de vie de sa famille il avait plus de
boulot quoi les autres il étaient
contents parce que et en plus il est
devenu socialiste militant ouis vous
avez raison voilà donc ça c'était le
point de départ de ça j'ai dit non
j'arrête moi le lavage de cerveau
franchement c'est Pasut mais la France a
un vrai problème avec ça il y a qu'en
France où vous avez je sais pas moi le
socialisme à la SPD en
Allemagne Schroder moi je j'adhère à
Schroder je prends ma carte mais mais
socié français avec l'extrême gauche et
cetera qui dit n'importe quoi à part
puis puisil vendent de la haine quo je
me souviens de ce slogan que j'ai vu
dans dans dans ma dans ma commune ou
dans la circonscription c'est cétait
c'était le MJS ils avaient marqué enfin
pour hair les riches ouïir ils ont
marqué à eux les milliards à nous les
licenciements mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ces images enfin il y a 3 millions
d'entrepreneurs vous croyez que les mecs
quand ils voit ça ils ont pas envie de
partir c'est pas de l'information c'est
de la propagande et c'est c'est triste
vre première vraie engagement politique
c'était contre la guerre du Vietnam
c'est bien ça le conflit c'était dans
les années 50 donc vous avez grandi avec
vous avez 57 ans et on peut quand même
le préciser et c'est vers 16 18 ans un
peu plus tard plutôt même puisque
c'était dans les
années
66 67 ouii très jeune très jeune que
j'ai commencé à me sensibiliser et puis
effectivement vers la fin de la guerre
du Vietnam c'est 1970
1971 ces images un peu terribles je me
souviendrai toujours de à la télévision
cette image de la petite fille brûlée
par les bombes au napalme et donc et
puis derrière tous les événements le
Biafra la guerre du Biafra donc
effectivement les grandes causes de la
paix du développement dans le monde
m'ont toujours sensibilisé m'ont amené
politique on prend peut-être le fil
chronologique l'évolution de votre
parcours en politique 87 vous avez une
trentaine d'années vous vous installez à
La Verrière qu'est-ce qui a motivé cette
installation c'était déjà dans le but
ensuite d'accéder à la mairie de
commencer à prendre contact avec le
maire de l'époque Pierre céincour mais
emblématique de cette ville pas du tout
je travaillais dans le milieu de
l'animation à manth et puis le pas de
programme politique d'idée politique de
carrière politique moi je suis pas
contrairement à beaucoup qui commment
jeune dans la carrière politique et qui
n'ont que ça en tête c'est pas du tout
ça Mo j'étais un professionnel de la
jeunesse on on est venu me chercher pour
travailler à la verrière j'y ai
travaillé on m'y a fait confiance on m'a
confié des responsabilités
progressivement et j'ai toujours dit je
dois beaucoup à cette ville qui m'a
permis d'avoir un parcours professionnel
tout à fait
[Musique]
satisfaisant vous êes socialiste encarté
au Parti socialiste est-ce que c'est pas
trop difficile aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être dans ces momentsl où il faut
avoir le plus de recul c'estàdire
regarder les ch avec auteur enfin
essayer en tout cas rappeler aussi que
ce sont d'abord des des valeurs he qui
font nos convictions et pour pour ma
part mes valeurs restent tout à fait les
mêmes que ce soit les valeurs de
solidarité d'attention portée à l'autre
de refus du repli sur soi ou
d'individualisme comme on le voit trop
souvent en ce moment en tant que maire
moi je suis d'abord attaché à répondre
aux engagements pris devant les
habitants et ça je le fais au quotidien
tous les jours avec peut-être quand on
est élu local une difficulté
particulière c'est qu'on est à la fois
obligé de d'être dans le quotidien
chaque jour à à devoir gérer et en même
temps porter on en parlera sans doute
tout à l'heure une vision d'avenir
c'està-dire être en même temps qu'on
s'occupe du quotidien et du présent être
capable de porter une vision savoir où
on veut aller où on veut permettre à la
ville d'aller avec ses habitants avant
de parler de l'avenir on va parler
encore un peu du du passé avec votre
parcours vous n'êtes pas politicien de
formation vous avez été enseignanté
ignant voilà j'étais enseignant
spécialisé j'étais directeur d'école
enseignant spécialisé enseignant auprès
de les enfants du voyage c'est sans
doute dans cette approche que j'ai eu
mes premiers engagements les enfin en
tout cas les engagements les plus
profonds hein celui de des valeurs de
l'éducation justement et pourquoi
rentrer ensuite en politique bah ça
s'est passé j'allais dire petit à petit
euh d'abord je suis rentré dans l'équipe
municipale mon prédécesseur lonado m'a
proposé de rentrer dans l'équipe
municipale c'était lié justement à mon
engagement associatif et en direction de
l'école et puis c'est dans le cadre
municipal que finalement j'ai assez vite
compris
qu'il était nécessaire pas simplement
d'avoir des idées mais essayer de les
mettre en œuvre ces convictions
socialistes aujourd'hui elles sont mises
à mal c'est toujours difficile quand un
parti dirige en France et on le voit à
chaque changement de
majorité je suis pas quelqu'un de
Partisan donc quand j'ai des choses à
dire par rapport par rapport à mon parti
je le dis en interne je le dis aussi à
l'extérieur c'est le cas actuellement
sur la loi sur les
intercommunalités qui je pense est une
loi qui qui va trop vite c'est une loi
qui fait perdre la proximité donc voilà
je le dis j'ai aucun souci là-dessus
vous restez libre au sein du Parti
socialiste c'est ça mais vous gardez
votre carte au Parti socialiste la
liberté c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
pour tout le monde après il y a des
convictions des valeurs euh ces valeurs
existent au sein du parti socialistes
elles existent au sein de la gauche et
j'y travaille à l'intérieur aussi en
tant que militant comme tous les
militants pour pouvoir faire avancer les
idées vous êtes un homme de droite un
homme du centre aussi puisque vous avez
fait campagne par le passé avec le
soutien de l'UDF du MoDem de l'UMP vous
êtes où le plus à l'aise aujourd'hui je
suis à l'aise quand je suis Michel
logier tout simplement et vous ne voulez
pas d'étiquettes politiques j'ai mes
idées j'ai mes j'ai mes convictions je
suis un homme plutôt à droite mais
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir
une structure partisane autour de moi
ceux qui mêiment me suivent et je pense
que on peut aussi progresser faire des
choses sans forcément avoir une carte
dans son parti politique mais ça permet
de se dégager aussi de certaines
contraintes des partis d'être un peu
plus libre aussi lorsqu'on voit les
difficultés rencontré par exemple à
l'UMP vous vous dit je suis bien content
de pas y être en ce moment au moins ça
m'évite d'avoir pourquoi pas répondre à
des questions sur ça vous savez s'il y
avait que l'UMP ça serait facile mais
regardez dans tous les autres parties
c'est exactement aussi la même chose
donc j'ai été militant j'ai été même
délégué départemental de l'UDF pendant
plusieurs années et aujourd'hui je n'ai
plus retrouvé une famille dans laquelle
je me sente parfaitement bien et à
l'aise sauf que aujourd'hui la véritable
politique que l'on mène c'est celle
qu'on mène sur le terrain et celle qui
est reconnue par les par les habitants
après la reste c'est la politique
politicienne et vous êtes bien au centre
aujourd'hui politique le centre c'est ce
qui vous convient parfaitement je pense
c'est ce qui me convient parfaitement
parce que justement il y a il y a un
équilibre il y a une recherche
d'équilibre recherche d'harmonie je
trouve par rapport au décisions qu'il a
à prendre et moi je je m'y retrouve
parfaitement vos convictions de gauche
vos convictions communistes sont né à
quel moment à quel moment vous vous êtes
dit je vais m'engager de cette manière
là et vers cette ce parti là c'est
difficile moi je je suis un un enfant de
Bonlieu je suis c'est souvent comme ça
que je me définis j'ai j'ai passé toute
mon enfance à sarcell donc dans les
milieux de gauche forcément à la grande
époque de la gauche des idées de la
gauche et donc de gauche je le suis
quasiment depuis que j'ai la capacité de
réfléchir et de penser je suis un je me
suis engagé très tôt à 14 ans j'étais
déjà un militant politique plutôt
l'extrême gauche d'ailleurs et puis j'ai
rejoint le Parti communiste en 1985 donc
il y a presque 30 ans
voilà parce que c'est ma famille
naturelle je suis un petit peu un petit
peu particulier je suis pas un homme de
parti je ne fréquente pas les les
cercles des des militants et autres je
suis plutôt j'ai envie de mon
indépendance aussi de garder mes idées
sensibilité mais oui j'aime bien être ce
que je suis aujourd'hui ça veut dire
quoi être communiste justement B être
communiste c'est je pense que c'est ce
ne plus s'éloigner des idées de justice
sociale des idées de de développement
pour l'humain c'est c'est finalement
revenir à ces valeurs fondamentales qui
nous manquent tant qui nous manqu tant
celle de la place de l'homme la place de
de la démocratie effectivement la
participation la citoyenneté et puis la
place du rapport aux éléments
fondamentaux de la vie c'est-à-dire le
travail l'amitié la construction commune
de de l'avenir et donc ce sont des des
valeurs c'est un système de valeurs
après derrière il y a des parties des
organisations on peut être d'accord ou
pas d'accord sur la totalité mais je
crois que l'esprit effectivement de
vouloir une société meilleure une
société plus juste reste d'actualité
c'estuve mais non mais non c'est pas du
ça peut s'ppiquer ça peut se traduire
concrètement bien
[Musique]
sûr il y a pas de carrière il y a pas
d'ambition c'est ce que vous nous dites
depuis le début de cette de cet échange
qu'on a ici euh pour autant dans 5 10
ans vous voyez où toujours MRE de manie
Lamo euh éventuell
conseiller départemental je vous pose la
question parce que vous étiez candidat
en 2008 tout à fait au derniè
départemental j'avais été candidat donc
en 2008 pour pour notre canton ça a été
une belle expérience j'y ai porté
certaines certaines idées pour notre
territoire il y a encore beaucoup à
faire est-ce que vous serez présent sur
le le ticket qui sera présenté par le
Parti socialiste j'aiderai les personnes
qui iront et je ne me présenterai pas je
suis maire de ma commune et et j'assume
cette FO fonction pleinement et d'autres
personnes iront comme vous parlez du
National un poste de secrétaire d'État
un poste de ministre ça ne nous a jamais
aussi intéressé est-ce que vous avez été
sollicité pour ça mais monsieur Chirac
m'avait proposé la le ministère de la
politique de la ville il y a quelques
années que que je n'ai pas accepté parce
que je venais juste d'ord d'être député
j'avais une circonscription qui était
pas facile voilà ça me semblait pas très
raisonnable d'aller bon franchement la
suite maintenant soutz Nicolas vous
soutenez Nicolas Sarkozi pour la
présidence de de l'UMP et pourquoi pas
aussi pour pour 2017 ça fait partie des
des discussions que vous auriez pu avoir
avec lui aussi écoutez je je je ne sais
pas je connais bien ces gens-là bon on
va pas se le cacher mais je sais qu' il
m'aime bien et que au travers des
propositions que je fais ils en prennent
un certain nombre donc mais vous dire
que je cherche un post ministre non j'ai
une vie de famille
sympathique j'ai trois enfants j'ai avec
ma femme on s'entend bien
enfincl pas l'autre la en cours ça me
passionne pour l'instant en tout cas
c'est pas c'est pas à l'heure du jour et
je je ne réfléchis même pas là-dessus
même en rasant je je connais expression
le café politique se referme nous
quitterons cquenttin en iveline pour
plaisir lors du prochain numéro
Joséphine colmans berger la mre UMP
participera à l'émission ce sera à
découvrir sur notre antenne à partir du
10 janvier et d'ici là très bonne fête
de fin
[Musique]
d'année